welcome to bit by bit a series where we
highlight one thing you can do to
optimize and potentially run a bit
better in Google Cloud today's topic
making sure we're more efficient with
resources in our gke standard clusters
one way to do that is by configuring the
cluster Auto scaler in gke with the
optimize utilization Auto scaling
profile let's get to it
[Music]
the kubernetes cluster autoscaler is the
gold standard for making sure your
cluster can add or remove nodes based on
demand my favorite thing about the
cluster Auto scaler in gke is that
Google fully manages the software it's
one less cluster component lifecycle
that we have to worry about so in this
demo we're going to use these two
clusters each with cluster Auto scaler
enabled but with one main difference in
gke the way you influence this fully
manage cluster autoscaler is by
configuring Auto scaling profiles these
inform the cluster Auto scalers Behavior
so the default Auto scaling profile is
set here in our California gke cluster
it's called balanced
this means it prioritizes keeping more
resources readily available for incoming
pods
our organ cluster on the other hand has
a different Auto scaling profile called
optimize utilization
this makes the cluster Auto scaler scale
down nodes more aggressively to be more
resource efficient
so we're going to run an experiment to
see the difference between these two
clusters and the respective Auto scaling
profiles
so we can see here that they have the
same node count and they have the same
amount of CPU and memory
and we can use the Kube CTL command line
tool to check in on them and make sure
that they are also running the same
workload
so we can see California is running a
deployment called Alpha with 45 pods and
we're now going to use codectx to switch
over to the Oregon cluster you can see
that it's running the same deployment
same number of pods and then what we're
going to do now is we're going to delete
the workload or this deployment in each
of them and watch how the Oregon gke
cluster scales down more aggressively
than the California gke cluster with the
default Auto scale profile
so we're going to delete the deployment
in the organ cluster switch contacts to
our California cluster and then delete
the deployment there as well
[Music]
and so that'll take a moment so in the
meantime let's take a look at previous
scale down experiments I ran before this
demo in our cluster Auto scaler logs
[Music]
so even though the cluster Auto scaler
in gke is a fully managed component it
is nice to have its logs automatically
sent to Cloud login for us
in our logs Explorer here I have two
saved queries one for each of the gke
Clusters in this demo to give us
insights into scale down events that
happen in each cluster
so let's jump into the query for the
organ cluster with the optimize
utilization profile
and so I won't get bogged down in query
syntax but you'll see here that we're
looking for logs from the auto scaler
for our organ cluster and it's only node
pool and we're specifically looking for
scale down events in this cluster that
happened when the ratio of requests from
pods running on a node that was scaled
down to its total allocatable resources
was over 50 percent
this signals a more aggressive scale
down of nodes that might have less spare
allocatable resources but spare
resources nonetheless
and so we see here in many cases cluster
Auto scaler did make a decision to scale
down these nodes
if we dig down into one of the
individual scale down events we can see
this information
so if we click down in here and we take
a look at the individual node we see
that the memory requests to Total
allocatable ratio for this node that was
scaled down was at 60 percent
now keep in mind cluster Auto scaler
will only scale down a node if it knows
that it can schedule the pods running on
that node to another node in the cluster
but of course there's still the
trade-off that if you turn down more
nodes the workloads on those nodes are
evicted and have to restart elsewhere so
in this case we had three that were on
this node that was scaled down so this
is when choosing an auto scaling profile
becomes a trade-off of efficient
resource utilization versus how tolerant
your workloads actually are of the
potential disruption
and so now we're going to run the exact
same query in the California GK cluster
with the balanced Auto scaling profile
we're actually not going to get any
scaled on events over the the same time
window right and then the reason that
this is occurring is that more often
than with the optimized utilization
profile the balance profile is
preferring to keep resources readily
available for incompods as opposed to
aggressive scale down and so now we'll
jump back to our original demo and we
can see that the expected Behavior has
occurred we can see that the Oregon gke
cluster with the optimized utilization
cluster Auto scaling profile has scaled
down more aggressively than the
California GK cluster with the balanced
cluster Auto scaler Auto scale and
profile
and so you know when it comes to
Resource efficiency scale down
efficiency is a big part of it but
there's also optimizations that we can
have at schedule and time to make sure
that of the spare resources on our nodes
that we use them that we use them all
right so when you take a look at the
Oregon cluster with the optimize
utilization profile
you can see that we have two nodes and
we'll look at the node with the suffix
h02a and we can see that CPU it has more
CPU requests than the other node and
about you know it's about a wash for
memory requests and so when it comes to
utilizing the optimize utilization
profile
uh let's take a look at how this pod
will get scheduled here so we have a pod
requesting 100 Mil core of CPU
um and so what we would expect with the
optimize utilization profile is that
this would actually land on the h02a
nodes we're gonna we just applied it we
created it and we should see that it was
scheduled to that node
and so the reason it gets scheduled to
this node is that when you use this
optimize utilization profile it's
influencing the cube scheduler to place
these nodes on more heavily utilized
nodes to make sure again that although
spare capacity that sometimes can be
left idle that we're actually taking
advantage of it and using it when we can
prefers the schedule node pods to these
nodes that again are more heavily
utilized and so the way that it actually
influences the cube scheduler is that
when you enable this feature or this
Auto scaling profile on a gke cluster we
will then inject this scheduler name gke
optimize utilization scheduler to
basically influence a cube scheduler to
perform this Behavior at scheduling time
as well
scaling down nodes more aggressively and
scheduling workloads so that we get the
most from our nodes can make things a
bit better with resource efficiency in
gke so check out the optimize
utilization Auto scaling profile as
always you can learn more in the links
in the description below and we'll see
you in a bit
[Music]